you did a hot boxing with mike tyson and
i mean the first half hour you were
talking about
things that you used to do and things
that you're doing now so my question
revolves around personal growth
you're now a vegan
you used to say you know you eat meat
whatever you used to party
smoke drink whatever that you know that
kind of lifestyle now you're doing
mushrooms you have your meta toad yeah
um you know you talked about dmt i've
done dmt that shit's wild i've done some
mushrooms uh mom hope you're not
listening
um
but my question is like you've grown up
clearly you've got like you got it going
on bro like you you're you're like the
the the you're knocking people out in
the ring but here just like you're
very chill casual dude the personal
growth
when did you have to grow up
um and what did like what you're doing
now with your because your company is it
meditate is that what it is yeah
mettaton just explain the personal
growth and where you're at even with
your diet your health your exercise your
mentality your emotions things that
you're putting in your body where's that
all at um you know
i i felt like i needed to grow up and
just you know when i just kept bumping
my head you know and just having things
setbacks happen to me and just trying to
figure out like where
where it was coming from you know and
how i was my own worst enemy and how i
kept on causing myself to re have these
same repeating patterns in my life
and you know facing a lot of part of my
a lot of the part of myself that i
didn't want to face before you know and
you know i um i point to psychedelics
not because i'm like everybody needs to
you know use psychedelics in order to
get to
to find truth but
um
using psychedelics allow me to get
perspective you know
the only thing that can help you get
perspective without it is time you know
but sometimes you don't have time you
know and um
being able to get the perspective that i
have when i was you know using
psychedelics allowed me to see areas in
myself that i was you know i needed to
change in areas i needed to confront and
and those you know was was the spawn of
another that was the spawn of me you
know changing and wanting to do better
for myself and uh you know doing you
know doing better for people that are
affected you know by being a certain
kind of way and um
that was only something that
only i could do for myself there was
only something that i i had to see for
myself but you know i wasn't able to see
for myself because i was caught in that
habitual pattern of just doing the same
thing and not being able to see you know
uh where i was coming up short and so uh
it's been it's been a different uh
different path for me and that's why
even when i even came back to fighting
you know just just because i want to
feel it from this perspective you know i
fought from one perspective for the
longest time but i never fought you know
in this perspective and i wanted to just
you know have that and experience that
because you know i've um i've grown so
much
in this area where i just wanted to see
what it would be like now
it's it's hard to fight from a from a
place of of
you know confidence like that from your
in yourself so much of fighting comes
from self-hatred and self-loathing and
you know externalizing a lot of the
things that that you know you've
internalized your whole life so now when
you find peace
the is there any fear
that you won't have that same rage you
won't be able to unleash that that same
you know get yourself into that same you
know violent primordial being you need
to be to face another man like that um
that's a good question i feel like
that's um one of the things that kind of
led to me not fighting the way i felt
like i needed to fight in the last few
fights is because you know i found peace
in a lot of different areas where
i was struggling before you know uh you
know fighting has been therapy for me to
be honest you know and some of the
things that i was working through in
life i found a way to work through them
through fighting but um
now as a fighter and and where i'm at
right now
i don't feel like i need to be angry or
have the the feelings of of that that
dog you know um
in that kind of way you know now i know
how to
how to hit a switch and mentally bring
myself to that point and you know
unleash that beast and be savage when i
need to be and at the same time you know
be another way when i need to be it's
not just you i mean you know you look at
guys in the nfl they don't know that at
the end of their career they can turn it
off or even in the off season they can't
turn it off yeah you look at dudes that
are fighting you look at soldiers that
come back i mean when you're and it's
not necessarily their fault when you're
trained to be a hammer
all you're going to see is nails right
you know so i mean
in that regard i mean it's it's a really
interesting you're almost like a case
study you're a case study for for you
know professionally violent people yeah
to see if they can kind of turn it on
turn it off and if it can be controlled
violence or if that just kind of takes
over your personality yeah i mean it's
uh it's a very uh interesting process to
be honest because you know you
you have this mindset where you know you
are
a fighter
and
you know when you
engage that beast enough times it just
becomes who you are on so many different
levels so then when you don't have it
anymore you have to find a new way to
uh let it out you know without letting
it out in an uncontrolled manner that is
not acceptable anymore because you know
the best thing about
the 15 minutes of fighting is the fact
that that's your chance to let it all
out you know be the animal that you want
to be and it feels good it feels good to
just let it out but you're not always
going to have that in life so you have
to find different avenues to to let it
out in and i've been fortunate enough to
learn how to do that outside of fighting
and now that i felt like i've learned
how to do that i feel like you know i'm
ready to fight again yeah that's you
know the famous quote i mean this goes
back to what uh pat was saying about jon
jones you know the problem is you stare
into the darkness long enough and
eventually the darkness stares back
right so
you know if jon jones is trained to be a
fighter and there's nothing there's
nobody in front of him to fight he's
going to start fighting himself yeah
these other guys find that you you know
said one other thing life outside of
fighting you know for guys you see so
many great great great champions that
they they don't know when to walk away
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]